So you've built the
next great mobile app,
but users are complaining
that the experience isn't
always consistent.
They're calling it
slow and hitchy.
And they say that
it doesn't scroll
as smoothly as they'd like.
My name is Colt
McAnlis, and it sounds
like your app has a serious
rendering performance problem.
But don't worry.
We can fix this by
taking a look at how
Android is working
under the hood.
Rendering performance is the
most common performance issue
that you run into
while building an app.
On the one hand,
your designers want
to produce the most usable,
transcendent experience
for your users.
But on the other hand, all those
fancy graphics and transitions
may not work well
on every device.
So let's take a look at what
rendering performance is all
about.
Firstly, know that
the system will
attempt to redraw your activity
every 16 milliseconds or so,
which means that your
application needs
to run all the
logic that updates
the screen in that
16-millisecond frame
in order to hit 60
frames per second.
If you miss that window-- let's
say you take 24 milliseconds--
you start to get what
we call a dropped frame.
The system tried to draw a
new picture on the screen,
but one wasn't ready yet.
So it didn't refresh anything.
The user ends up seeing the
same graphic for 32 milliseconds
rather than for 16.
This effect of missed
frames is at the core
of what a user would call a
laggy or janky experience.
Any animations that
are going on during a
dropped frame will see a jump
in their smoothness, which
users can easily see.
It gets even worse when
this effect happens
while the users are interacting
with the system-- for example,
dragging a ListView or
typing in some data.
This is what users quickly
start to complain about.
There's a whole group
of reasons that you
could miss your
16-millisecond frame window.
For example, you may be
spending too much time
redrawing large parts of
your View hierarchy, which
wastes CPU cycles.
Or you might be drawing
too many objects
on top of each other, which
wastes valuable time coloring
in pixels that aren't
visible to the final user.
Or you could be doing a ton
of animation over and over
and over again, which can cause
large amounts of churn on both
your CPU and GPU components.
Detecting and fixing
these problems
is highly dependent on
how your app is built.
But generally, it comes down
to using the available tools
to track down and identify
what's going wrong.
For example, you can
use Hierarchy Viewer
to understand if your
activity is too complex, which
can lead to issues with spending
too much time invalidating
or wasting time redrawing.
You can also use the On-Device
Tools, like Profile GPU
Rendering, Show GPU Overdraw,
and GPU View Updates,
to get a better sense of
where in your application
you're running into problems.
And for those tricky rendering
bugs that manifest themselves
in CPU code, Traceview
is a great tool
to track down what's causing
a missed 16-millisecond frame.
Rendering performance is one
of the easiest performance
problems to fall into, but
don't let that stop you
from making an amazing app.
Check out the rest of the
Android Performance Patterns
resources.
And don't forget to join
our Google+ community.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
Perf Matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]